look at this I got my Korean castor hair
back hot Allah Jesus is a way of a Hall
of your life
Oh what is going on YouTube now we all
know that if you're Asian is only
customary that you take off your shoes
before you enter somebody's house now
when it comes to doing this I hadn't
really taken too much thought into it
because it's something that I grew up
with but of course as I got older and I
started opening up my circle I started
to realize that not everybody does this
and if you really didn't do it I I don't
have a shirt I hate it when I ask
somebody to politely take off their
shoes before they enter my home and they
look at me as if I asked them to do the
most difficult task on earth Oh for real
dog is taking off your damn shoes
someone's about see sometimes I just
need you to take the wheel
because I will run a [ __ ] over but if
you have asked people to do this
politely and you don't know what to tell
them to take off their shoes this is
what you need to tell them and it's been
a while but you already know what it is
LGI baby let's get it let's go here's
the first reason because it's my [ __ ]
house doesn't it you can't respect the
rules uh you could get the [ __ ] on up
you know whatever reason comes after
this it really isn't that important
because what other reason do you need
how about you go have the ball sack to
come in somebody else's home and tell
them what the [ __ ] rules are gonna
get sliced oh well but first can you
I'll explain the logic behind it first
of all you better take the tonnage of
goddamn boys second if you don't try to
get shot do you pay rent here do you
live here are you gonna clean this
[ __ ] floor or carpet before you leave
if the answer's no [ __ ] kill you lil
well it's my shoes my body and America
is a free country what the [ __ ] is
America had to do with you [ __ ] up my
carpet and know to be completely honest
with you you are absolutely wrong about
that last statement
the moment you step into my house and
suddenly became North Korea and I had
Ken drop her Monica I get [ __ ] I don't
care what you do at your house that is
your domain your carpet you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want with it you
can go home spread you little booty
cheeks wipe it on the [ __ ] floor
snort coke off a hookers butt crack I
don't give a [ __ ]
the nannies a simp are you look I don't
want to take off of your shirt
you could good bye but it's my body
don't tell me what to do with it
somebody out there just pray for rain so
I could drown a [ __ ] you mother look at
you always playing the victim shut the
[ __ ] up Harvard all of the dumbest
[ __ ] excuses what did my feet smell
then is the shoe the real problem here
maybe you should wash your ass every now
and then you're [ __ ] nasty [ __ ]
walking around with Joe biblical looking
at speed do the world a favor chop off
your [ __ ] toes and here's another
funny thing you knew the fact that I was
an immigrant you know the fact that I
got a long Korean past ahead Jesus save
everybody you smell the kimchi in the
fridge what the [ __ ] were you expecting
you saw a lot of network television
growing up you saw a lot of [ __ ] about
being culturally sensitive so you didn't
want to assume but white people on this
one shit's true
listen at a certain point it's not even
a race for ethnicity thing it's just a
common sense hygiene thing they're just
you know Asian people got it right
that's all listen think about it like
this you walk around all over the place
with those shoes where there is [ __ ]
piss and yes occasional semen
I wanna trace your little crusty ass
shoes all over my [ __ ] floor but it's
not even muddy there's no dirt see
charms and hepatitis eight visible [ __ ]
unless you got some microscopes for
eyeballs
oh listen even if Barack Obama himself
scrapes his [ __ ] shoes onto my carpet
your best believe he better take off
those goddamn shoes I'm not used
presently get on a knee with those dirty
ass shoes [ __ ] but I lost if I did meet
you I'd be very honored but take off
your goddamn shoes
now on now I haven't taken too much
started this a hacker with the pool with
the bat pretty baby